[Applause]
can i tell you the most impressive part
of this what's up
so right now we're looking at adele and
she's donning uh
jamaican bikini top uh she's
lost a lot of weight looking good
yeah she looks i mean
i think adele is more attractive fat and
i know i went on a little tirade about
how they're ending the world
but i think she's more attractive fast
every day andrew gets more and more
black
it's what i do i'm wearing green chubby
white girl sir
i'm complimenting chubby white women
shooting guns at everyone
shooting guns at everybody whoa mark
that was racial
that was racial yeah racial not racial
not racist thank you okay now
here's the thing about this i am so
impressed
mind-bogglingly impressed she got
eyebrows like marks
she has a strong brow she has a strong
brow
i am so mind-bogglingly impressed with
the
density of her bosoms i was just
thinking that
she still got him usually when a fat
loses weight
their bosoms shrink shrink and flatten
they usually pancake they pancake like
the things at the end of the 18-wheeler
that stop the mud from mud flaps if you
will
they mud flap this girl's bosom
seemed to be as dense if not more dense
than when she was fat which leads me to
believe
i'm more dense but they're dense maybe
all this weight loss was not
natural that she was actually in a fat
suit the whole time
what i thought
and that's why she chose not to lipo the
titty area
no kept her fat cells in the titty area
you can't get lipo from
your entire body like that why not like
you can get it from certain areas what's
the freezing one where you freeze fat
what's that [ __ ] called
cool sculpt yeah cool sculpt she could
have cool stuff your entire body
she probably had some natural weight
loss a little bit and then yeah
why not or she got fat inserted back
into her bosoms
oh that's a great move honestly if you
lose a lot of weight i think that's what
a lot of girls are doing
fluff up them pancakes girl fluff up
them [ __ ] put a little butter in them
or damn right
breast implants but if she put it under
the muscle it looks more natural and
they tend to hang more so they look
real look so you're the expert on white
women
so i'm going to go with what you say and
that's possibly this
but i don't understand why this is a big
controversy
she's wearing a jamaican uh flag bikini
top
who gives a [ __ ] what's the big deal
it's the
image like it's really not a controversy
for people
in london and people who go to notting
hill carnival
it's like a west indian carnival
and they usually all dress up like this
and they encourage people of all races
you don't have to be west indian to
attend this yeah but
just the imagery that americans are used
to like oh we see
a white girl doing anything black black
appropriation we got to come down here
we were saying cultural appropriation
yeah
because she's gotten the break she got
the jamaican thing she lost a bunch of
weight like a starving kid
she did all that wow no i'm sorry
whoa
that was crazy ow you okay bro i'm
recovering
jesus christ
okay okay andrew uses that fourth i got
four more loaded
ready you're all out now i got one left
no you shot three shots yeah you're
cheating too
have i shot at you you cheated to it
i got one left hey all right just to
wrap up this
adele thing i think it's important
because a lot of people are hating on
adele right now she's getting a lot of
hate
but here's a question that
i don't think a lot of people ask but i
think it's something that conversation
that we should absolutely have
who's black or adelaide
i knew it i knew it i knew i was coming
with some [ __ ] right now
i don't know that was nice for them
malcolm x right now
i saw the whole thing it was beautiful
al lifted his gun at the screen and i
was like what is going on and then he
just
but no that's funny he's covered with
some [ __ ]
who's black or beyonce oh my god who's
blacker
blasphemy who's blacker continue i'm
listening
beyonce yeah right
okay all right now i'm back who do you
think is blacker i'm
waiting people are saying adele i'm
waiting for you to explain
so i can hop on board all right
[ __ ] choo choo
choo choo names
adele definitely blacker than beyonce
yeah
what beyonce that's a french
that's very common got the accent on it
and everything that's a common french
name you mean a million beyonce's you go
to the south of france you go to san
tropez
yeah really really you've met a million
of them you do man you go to san tropez
bro
beyonce every other block every other
difference you get a little cafe au lait
from a beyonce a little cigar with the
[ __ ] the black
god boom exactly adele historically
black name
adele gibbons yep wow
i'll look some others up okay adele
jenkins
adele harris adele harris adele johnson
uh del phillips i think that's all adele
jackson adele jackson
yeah i can't just put a black last day
behind it what's the black last name
that's that is crazy right there what
you just said what you just said
is very racial and it even could
borderline on racists
what we're trying to do is have a
discussion whether beyonce is
blacker than adele i happen
to leave these up to the people i can
only present the people with the
information that's out there
adele's name clearly blacker okay
oh how many more look at how many more
people are named black people are named
adele than her name beyonce i'll take
that one
for 100 alex
yeah think about it there's way more
black adeles than there are black
beyonce's
so she wins the name category nah her
name is original
huh her name is original like um it was
a play off her mom's maiden name
so it's like they created what was her
mom's maiden name it was like uh
bientz that don't sound black
and it's that don't sound black it's
creole french
creole is white french's
white creole's white i think so it's
white for black people
it's white for black and the white is
black people so way more black adeles
they're way more black adeles than there
are black beyonce's we just know that
because beyonce is just made up
so that she still loses she's the losers
now but making up a name making up a
name
very black very very white very black
they call
their little kids acaibo
you never had these hollywood
celebrities make up names for little
kids
but no originality that's not only
something that already exists
call your side mr you say you're gonna
marry but you never do beyonce
okay adele definitely wins blackness and
then blacker when it comes to name
that we know for a fact singing
who sings blacker who sings blacker
[ __ ] that's a good question who has a
stronger
beautiful black woman voice
why because adele has the fat black
woman
strong and then white people made her
lose weight yeah but we don't know if
she can sing anymore she hasn't dropped
the song since that's true
that's the widest thing she did was lose
weight the white listen there's no doubt
that now she's becoming whiter and
that's why she's trying to grab on to
the blackness she's putting on jamaican
flags on her titties you know me and got
her hair all up in the twists look like
[ __ ] kodak white
she look like kodak she does
look like marlon wayne's refried what is
it don't be amazed
yeah fake friday yeah so the point is
point is in terms of hair
who's got blacker hair
i'll give you another point adele is
dating
skepta that's the word on the street oh
[ __ ] black rapper
they're both team black rappers that is
true you're all right
but complexion-wise skeptic's darker
wow wow complexion-wise
shade shaymin out here who says shade
we're giving it's beautiful
yeah darker is beautiful we're saying a
scoreboard yeah board scoreboard
so we're saying jesse's not as black not
as skeptical
as black nah they're black jay-z with
the helmet backwards
jay-z
bro yeah skepter would never do that bro
this is a this is a good point
adele adele dating
skepta skeptic trumps jay-z
nope in terms of blackness never yes nah
yes in terms of their voice bare minimum
jay-z sounds like a third grader
jay-z sounds like he should be in a john
mullaney show so skeptical
disrespecting jesus sounds like he's
being a special
true advice don't know about that but
jay-z doesn't he seem like he wants to
be in the fourth grade
like he's just like
[Laughter]
what's your favorite thing for china
i've never heard jay-z sound like okay
ready okay
so so far adele's got a little lead
adele
is listen this is how you game the
youtube algorithm just let us roll with
it
okay ready listen adele so far
okay give us more things did you [ __ ]
your ex at me
okay you got some more things you got a
point dancing
okay there you go beyonce has that
beyonce
clearest day she got it if you had to
eat one of their macaroni and cheeses
or potato salads no
i'm talking about fat adele you don't
think she lost it you think she lost her
skill when she got skinny
fat adele cooking
soul food over skinny beyonce
cooking soul food who do you think makes
the better macaroni and cheese
beyonce's has been getting a little
thick lately so i'm going beyonce
i mean cooking actually getting better
she's starving herself
she's got private chefs doing all that
adele was eating mayonnaise sandwiches
for 10 years before she blew down
no she wasn't she was frying cats she
didn't blow up she's crying
one of them is frying catfish fat adele
or beyonce where are you going
keep it you don't have a brains wherever
she can fry fish
i'm still going to be olive oil every
song adele is
crying about losing a guy that means she
can't cook jason is wearing
an avocado ice cream no she's crying
about getting cheated on because she
dates mad black dudes
nice that i i cannot confirm or do
nothing
okay you [ __ ]
everybody
okay now back to what we're doing
what other categories go
what other categories are there who's
black or adele or beyonce just i could
be a hundred
keep it a hundred be honest beyonce
wears
way more colors and animal print that's
black italian no that's italian
has a wider credit score probably
beyonce should probably 800
[ __ ] 899 that's a [ __ ] fantastic
point
whose bank accounts whiter oh yo
beyonce pay me in equity payment equity
oh my god man she's a smart black woman
there's no question that she's pretty
black
but compared to adele bro i don't know
if you want to compare those two bruh
adele's from london okay minority white
british
oh what that's a great point in london
white british are a minority wow
is a minority oh she is a minority
american in 20 years she is a minority
in her home
country what's blacker than that
wow
oh my god bars you stupid [ __ ] idiot
so do you admit adele is blacker than
beyonce
so i can relate to her struggle it's a
hard one
he's getting turned on as we speak or
turned off oh yeah
anyway free adult man let her live her
life man she's trying to scoop up
she's gonna scoop up some dangling all
right um
let's just scoop up some dangling bro
that's it let her put the jamaican shits
on her titties
you